sehr geehrte damen und herren ich
begrüße sie herzlich zur pressekonferenz
mit verteidigungsministerin klaudia
tanner und dem präsidenten des
gemeindebundes alfred riedl und ich darf
die verteidigungsministerin versuchen zu
beginnen
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte damen und herren ich freue mich
sehr sie alle heute hier begrüßen zu
dürfen
wenn ich heute mit dem präsidenten des
österreichischen gemeindebundes hier
stehe dann stehe ich mit dem
interessensvertreter hier der 70 prozent
der österreichischen bevölkerung
vertritt und die interessensvertretung
für 2084 gemeinden wahrnimmt und wir
haben noch etwas gemeinsam wir waren
unglaublich beschäftigt während der
korona krise für die gemeinden für das
österreichische bundesheer waren es
besondere herausforderungen die wir zu
bewältigen hatten ich denke wie schon
seit jahrzehnten nicht millionen von
arbeitsstunden sind geleistet worden
beim testen in den gemeinden bei
einreise kontrollen bei uns im
bundesheer was so dass wir zeitweise bis
zu 8000 soldatinnen und soldaten im
einsatz hatten und wir wirklich auch
jeden tag bewiesen haben dass unser herr
die strategische reserve der republik
ist und sehr geehrte damen und herren
das müssen wir auch in diesen stunden
wieder beweisen nämlich bei
naturkatastrophen wenn wir gerade jetzt
aktuell an die beiden gemeinden in
niederösterreich denken die durch
hagelschäden verwüstet worden sind dann
kommt doch hier das bundesheer zum
einsatz aber andere gefahren wie zum
beispiel cyberangriffe letztes jahr auf
das außenministerium
terroranschläge der furchtbare anschlag
am zweiten november des letzten jahres
immer wieder mussten wir unter beweis
stellen dass wir immer da sind wenn wir
gebraucht werden es gibt aber etliche
weitere bedrohungen die uns zwar noch
nicht in diesem ausmaß getroffen haben
aber unser risiko bild
sagt uns dass sie mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit kommen werden wenn
sie nur an szenarien wie blackouts
denken in diesen vielen in diesen
unzähligen einsätzen konnten wir auch
viel an erfahrung gewinnen wir konnten
sehen was die schlüsselbereiche sind die
für erfolgreiche einsätze für die
bewältigung dieser notwendig sind neben
den militärischen belangen die
ausrüstung und personal ist eines ganz
besonders wichtig und das mussten wir in
dieser krise lernen das ist die
zusammenarbeit das ist die kooperation
mit den gemeinden das ist und bleibt der
schlüssel zum erfolg für die einsätze in
der jeweiligen region wir haben das
nicht nur beim testen in ganz österreich
gesehen in der vergangenheit das war
auch sichtbar bei hochwassern bei
katastropheneinsätzen so wie sie eben
jetzt auch stattfinden und es kommt noch
ein anderer aspekt dazu das
österreichische bundesheer ist gerade in
den regionen in den gemeinden stark
verankert sei es als arbeitgeber aber
auch als teil der tradition als teil der
kultur vor ort wenn sie daran denken
dass sie in wahrheit der militärische
lebensweg eines jeden mannes in der
gemeinde beginnt nämlich in dem moment
in dem die stellung der mine an den
gemeinde tafeln angeschlagen werden und
für viele geht es dann mit den angelow
bungen die er jetzt zum glück wieder in
größerem gewohnten ausmaß stattfinden
können weiter das sind großereignisse in
der gemeinde die auch gemeinsam
veranstaltet werden die hand vor diesen
militärischen wirtschaftlichen und
kulturellen hintergründen haben wir uns
entschieden und dafür ein großes danke
schön herr präsident diese
zusammenarbeit mit den gemeinden
vertreten durch den gemeindebund unter
dem verteidigungsministerium zu
institutionalisieren und wir haben
einige gemeinsame ziele festgelegt die
wir in einer gemeinsamen
absichtserklärung festgehalten haben die
wir heute unterzeichnen werden zum
ersten setzen wir uns dafür ein dass aus
dem kreis der mitglieder jedes
gemeinderates eine ansprechperson ein
ansprechpartner für das österreichische
bundesheer definiert wird um damit eben
die kommunikation und die zusammenarbeit
zwischen bundeswehr und den gemeinden zu
institutionalisieren und zu
intensivieren
zum zweiten im sinne der umfassenden
landesverteidigung insbesondere der
geistigen landesverteidigung werden wir
künftig informations offiziere für
vorträge über das österreichische
bundesheer und die aktuelle
bedrohungslage im rahmen von
gemeinderatssitzungen zur verfügung
stellen und in weiterer folge soll das
dann auch bei gemeindeveranstaltungen
angeboten werden und zum dritten soll
die laufende information der bürgerinnen
und bürger über der stellungs wesen über
sicherheitspolitische und wer politische
themen und auch die personal offensive
des bundesheeres über die
kommunikationskanäle der gemeinden
insbesondere eben die ortstafel auch
ausgebaut werden ja und nicht zuletzt
soll gemeinsamen übungen und konzepten
zur risiko katastrophenprävention sowie
der bewältigung dieser ereignisse
gearbeitet werden
wir wollen diese absichten gemeinsam
verfolgen und in kooperation vertreten
sie sehen sehr geehrte damen und herren
daher präsident und ich haben wir haben
sehr vieles vor mit den gemeinden mir
verbleibt jetzt mich zu bedanken herr
präsident für die gemeinsame
vorgehensweise und ich freue mich schon
wenn wir dann gemeinsam einen punkt nach
dem anderen abarbeiten werden
dankeschön dankeschön bitte herr
präsident
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
auch von meiner seite ein herzliches
grüß gott heute vormittag liebe frau
bundesminister vorweg gleich einmal ein
ganz ganz herzliches danke dir und
deinen soldatinnen und soldaten für die
stets england besondere zusammenarbeit
die es vor allem in situationen die
jungs lokal dann immer wieder sehr
betroffen machen und da ist es schon
eine tolle sicherheit zu wissen dass es
profis im hintergrund gibt die uns dann
helfen wenn wir mit unseren
organisationen mit unseren freiwilligen
einfach nicht mehr zurande kommen
das bundesheer ist seit vielen jahren
und jahrzehnten enger partner der
kommunen vor allem wenn es um lokale
ereignisse geht die uns besonders
besonders fordern wir haben das ist
schon angesprochen worden erst in der
letzten woche an der tschechischen
grenze gesehen wie rasch es denn
jemanden treffen kann und da braucht es
neben der geübten einsatz kette am ende
eine ausfallshaftung sozusagen wenn die
kraft der freiwilligen auch also
sozusagen zu ende geht und zum zweiten
da braucht es auch unterstützung wenn es
so dramatisch wird dass es ganz einfach
vor ort nicht mehr haltbar ist
und da ich erinnere mich da auch immer
wieder als eigener betroffener an das
hochwasser 2002 längeren einsatz dauern
ist es einfach unabdingbar dass wir um
hilfe rufen und daher darf ich dir heute
namens der österreichischen städte und
gemeinden im rahmen der situation vor
unterzeichnung unserer absichtserklärung
auch ein großes danke sagen dass das
bundesheer stets unter anführungszeichen
ein partner in diesen situationen war
und die eigene erfahrung 2002 hat ja
gezeigt bei knapp über 1000 evakuierten
personen in der eigenen gemeinde über
einen einsatz von zwei wochen es wäre
anders einfach nicht mehr möglich
gewesen
warum erzähle ich eine 20 jahre alte
geschichte
ich erzähle diese 20 jahre alte
geschichte auch deswegen weil sie bis
heute präsent ist bis heute sind die
menschen in meiner gemeinde dankbar für
das was vor 20 jahren passiert ist und
du kannst heute durchs dorf gehen und
jeder wird wissen also wie viel an
unterstützung und an nachbarschaftshilfe
aber auch an rund 200 soldatinnen und
soldaten die über viele viele tage also
bei uns geholfen haben
es zeigt diese diese situation die
gemeinschaft die zusammenhält die
letztendlich für jeden sozusagen
motivation ist auch gegenseitig zu
helfen braucht diese professionelle
begleitung wenn es dann so weit ist und
wenn es notwendig ist und es ist ein
ganz wichtiger baustein in unserer
gesellschaft ein ganz wichtiger teil des
sicherheitsbedürfnisses unserer
landsleute dass wir gerne begleiten und
vertiefen wollen
das bundesheer ist nun einmal ein ganz
wesentlicher sicherheitspartner aber
auch und das ist auch schon angesprochen
worden
ein wesentlicher arbeits und
wirtschaftsfaktor in der region mit den
280 kasernen die in den regionen draußen
mit rund 50 oder 55 tausend aktiven
soldatinnen und soldaten heißt es dass
wir auch da in enger beziehung mit dem
unbegrenzte mobilität hin und den umweg
umweg hätte ich gesagt man mit den mit
den unterstützungen die wir vor ort also
geben können
ein beachtlicher wirtschaftsfaktor das
heißt also ja wir sind die letzten
eineinhalb jahre besonders geprüft
gewesen und auch da haben wir gesehen
und du hast es schon angesprochen in der
korona käse immer dann wenn die
zivilgesellschaft an den rand des
machbaren kommt wenn die zivilen
einrichtungen an ihre grenzen kommen
dann wart ihr zur stelle bis hin in das
pflegeheim oder als er
selbstverständlich auch bei unseren
testungen den österreichischen
bürgermeisterinnen und bürgermeistern
wollen an dieser stelle auch dafür ein
ganz ganz herzliches danke dir also
sagen wir haben als gemeinden aber
gemerkt dass die gemeinden sich auch
zunehmend vorbereiten auf eventualitäten
die immer wieder diskutiert werden und
die mit einer gewissen
wahrscheinlichkeit uns auch treffen
werden ob das blackout ist ob das
zivilschutz ist ob das krisenvorsorge es
viele gemeinden haben in
unterschiedlichster form auch mit den
regionalen standorten der kasernen
als er sich da und dort so schon
vorbereitet nun freue ich mich ganz
offen gesagt über eine vertiefte
kooperation zwischen den gemeinden und
dem bundesheer warum das wir haben als
gemeindebund vor einigen jahren mit
unserem gemeinde ministerium als
beispiel eine kooperation gefunden dass
gemeinde ministerium als als als innen
ressort mit gemeinsam sicher hat uns
ganz deutlich vor augen geführt dass es
einen täglichen oder einen regelmäßigen
kontakt braucht dass es eine
kommunikation braucht um das gefühl das
sicherheitsgefühl zu vertiefen und
dieser enge austausch also mit den
gemeinderäten das hinschauen statt
wegschauen das ist unter
anführungszeichen letztendlich auch in
krisen prävention notwendig in der
vorsorge notwendig einfach das
bewusstsein sozusagen offen zu halten
was geht was ist wirtschaftlich
vertretbar in der vorsorge auch
gemeinsam also vorzubereiten
daher also mit einem
verteidigungsminister werden wir jetzt
so mit der verteidigungsministerin
entschuldige frau bundesminister jetzt
in den gemeinden die absicht haben einen
ansprechpartner in jeder gemeinde also
zu nominieren die infoveranstaltungen
mit der bevölkerung zu intensivieren
prävention und katastrophenschutzpläne
vorzubereiten
dort wo es notwendig ist und wo es
verstört wahrnehmbar ist dass uns etwas
treffern wird aber auch das ist ein
thema die kommunikation mit dem
österreichischen bundesheer auf dem
lokal
also zu vertiefen um
sicherheitspolitische und herres
politische debatte nach lokal zu führen
weil auch da ist ein bedürfnis in der
vertieften geistigen landesverteidigung
gespräche also zu führen
ich sag's sowie die presse es vor kurzem
erst gesagt hat es hat eine frau
bundesminister gebracht dass wir es tun
kommen ich habe ja die diskussion über
diese kooperation also jetzt mit
mehreren vorgängen hier immer so
begonnen zu debattieren und freue mich
natürlich ganz besonders dass es
gelungen ist nunmehr in stone zu kommen
und daher ein großes danke dir weil ich
zutiefst überzeugt bin dass es in jeder
österreichischen gemeinde das bedürfnis
ist zu wissen wer ist ansprechpartner
wer kann wenn es notwendig ist rasch
einspringen wer unter anführungszeichen
hat den kurzen den direkten draht um
etwas zu organisieren wenn es wenn es
notwendig ist und damit darf ich einfach
sagen herzlichen dank es wird wohl jede
gemeinde ihr interesse haben da eine
gewisse sozusagen sicherheitsdebatte zu
beginnen und auch das sicherheitsgefühl
mit ihren gemeinde bürgerinnen und
gemeindebürgern zu vertiefen
vielen dank für die zusammenarbeit ich
freue mich auf viel viel gemeinsame
arbeit jetzt klingt dank ich darf nun um
ihre fragen bieten zu warten bis das
mikrofon behindert ist
wenn es keine fragen gibt dann kommen
wir nun zur unterzeichnung der
vereinbarung
doch
gut herzlichen dank wir werden ihnen die
vereinbarung auch digital zu senden und
wenn es keine weiteren fragen gibt und
bedanke ich mich fürs kommen und beendet
die pressekonferenz dankeschön